ich fühle mich gut ich bin ganz ruhig
liegen ist gesichert bleiben ja ich weiß
nicht ob das hilft aber manche fragen
sagen dass autosuggestion gegen
flugangst helfen sollen 16 prozent der
deutschen haben flugangst und es ist
eine angst die nur sehr schwer genommen
werden kann droht nämlich nicht auf
fakten fliegen die tatsächlich das
sicher für verkehrsregeln sie angst
davor kann mit argumenten nicht genommen
werden wie sie trotzdem weniger wird und
warum menschen überhaupt zugang haben
was jetzt bei pixum 15 uhr herzlich
willkommen
ich habe tatsächlich flugangst eine ganz
andere als diejenigen die richtige flug
also die nächte haben warum fliegen bei
mir tatsächlich gefährlich ist das
erzähle ich gleich ich bin einige tage
unterwegs wenn ihr also vorschläge zum
thema reisen fortbewegung und weise habt
dann hab damit in die kommentare
wenn mir das passiert was ich befürchte
haltet ihr euch natürlich auf dem
laufenden
dank der etwas das uns in gefahren sind
dort unterzubringen aufmerksamer zu sein
schnell zu reagieren und in paris auch
mal schnell die kurve zu kriegen
eigentlich etwas sehr gutes und wie
kannst du weißt du in der nähe von
schlecht gelaunten und bewaffnet mafiosi
richtig möglichkeit da naturgemäß ein
hohes interesse daran haben zu überleben
ließ die schwelle angst bekommt aber
manchmal eben zu niedrig dann haben
menschen an vergangen kleinen total
ungefährlich gingen zum beispiel spinnen
und heimlich sein immer so sei unnötig
und für fliegen steht eben auch unnötig
überfällig und für die betroffenen
richtig goethe die reaktionen des
körpers sind bei diesen menschen schon
beim einsteigen so dass der körper auf
kampf oder flucht vorbereiten wird hörer
puls blutdruck schnellere atem und
weiter fallen führt dann ohne einen
kampf oder die möglichkeit zu fliehen zu
einer richtung situation man fängt an zu
schwitzen und zittern und ist es
ziemlich peinlich wenn das andere
passagiere bemerkten wasser standen
leider auch über auch nicht besser
machen aber warum haben menschen denken
gottes willen nur flug an
80 prozent der menschen die für gangs
haben haben ein problem damit die
kontrolle abzugeben
wir haben zum beispiel
führungspositionen inne und wind ist
einfach nicht gewohnt ihr schicksal in
die hände eines trennten für kinder sind
auch übrigens schlechte beifahrer und
oft ist der wohnt auch einfach
unkenntnis über die physik hinter dem
clean wobei sich die villinger nicht so
ganz sicher warum flugzeuge fliegen
da habe ich meine ein videofilm markt in
der videobefragung aber und das ist
entscheidend funktioniert ingenieure
kennen sehr gut
die grenze fliegen und dann sie kommt
ein verkehrsflugzeug
mathematisch ist fliegen nämlich
wiederum sehr gefragt wenn man die für
geschnitten aus dem fenster nicht mehr
sieht beides so weit oben sind dann ist
ein flugzeug an sein fenster verrät aber
lediglich fliesen ist einfach das
sicherste verkehrsmittel und nur in
katastrophenfilmen schütten wir ab sie
also am besten nicht ansehen oder ich
hab mal eine doku reihe über die
schlimmsten flugzeugkatastrophe ein
gewinn
die am besten auch nicht schaut ja und
was kann man dagegen tun experten raten
ja zum beispiel für autogenem training
aber tatsächlich nichts gutes außer man
tut es fehlt auch hier mit kurve wo zum
beispiel erst mal mit dem flugsimulator
angefangen wird die technik detailliert
erklärt wird und die mechanismen der an
erläutert werden wenn man es geschafft
haben einmal zu fliegen sollte man
einfach dranbleiben und immer wieder
fliegt irgendwann merkt man dann das
setzt bei den schlimmsten turbulenten
wettet magna als wenn man durch den
abgang strahl eine sagen ein flugzeug
geflogen ist finde ich heftig wenn das
flugzeug die landung ab bricht ja oder
das flugzeug in ein luftloch wirkstoff
kann so richtig abwärts gehen
das ist dann immer noch nicht ab die
dinger wollen einfach nicht vom himmel
fallen zumindest extrem sarah und warum
ich bammel vom fliegen habe ganz einfach
die verbindung zwischen meinen ohren und
meiner nase die aussagen gänge sind wir
zurecht wenn meine nase ist also beim
schnupfen
dann kann ich keinen druck ausgleich
machen und trotz allem genen und kaum
vergeht es dann unter extremen schwer
damit sich möglichkeiten hinter dem
trommelfell und ich höre so gut wie
nicht mehr aber in küchen habe ich das
mit nasentropfen ganz gut im griff und
ich brauche kaum noch angst zu haben
hier geht es übrigens zu dem video wo
ich mich zusammen mit denen er dem
umgekehrten physikalischen phänomene
flicken fitness- und der übrigen
flugangst wenn ihr über die flugangst
schreibt mir doch mal eure erfahrungen
in die kommentare und dann brauchte nur
noch vier ein abo aufs auge drückt mir
einen auf die glocke gegeben wenn wir
keinen blick wieder mehr verpassen also
besser